if you've just bought your first drone
or looking to start a drone business
you've come to the right place what's
going on guys my name is David Tom
Mitchell welcome back to the channel
last week we just surpassed 300
subscribers so thank you so much for
being a part of the family if you
haven't subscribed already check out a
little subscribe button below
smash it if that's what you're into and
let's get on with this video if you've
just gotten your first drone and are
ready to go fly it or if you're ready to
start a commercial drone business
there's a few things that you need to be
aware of today in 2019 there are five
laws to keep in mind before you go out
and fly a drone basically every single
time regardless of the situation the
first Australian law is the fact that
your drone should always be visible in
sight so if it goes behind a building or
behind some trees and you can't actually
see your drone physically well this is
an issue and you need to move yourself
to be able to see your drone or move the
drone this also connects to another part
of the drone laws in Australia and the
fact that you can only fly a drone
during the daytime so obviously
nighttime you can't really see your
drone daytime you can see your drone
pretty easily the second law that's
restricted by country and geographical
location is a maximum altitude from
takeoff point right now in Australia we
have a maximum altitude of 120 metres
from takeoff point and also a minimum
restriction of 30 metres above sea level
for any wildlife photography or
videography so if you're looking to get
some great content of some wildlife or
potentially some whales and dolphins
something amazing in the ocean or
something amazing on the land well make
sure that your drone is at least 30
metres above the take-off point and that
way you're going to be able to crop it
down and post and make sure we don't
cause any harm to these beautiful
animals in our country the third law is
a pretty basic one and there's been a
lot of people get in trouble recently by
not abiding by this law this isn't just
speaking in Australia this is speaking
worldwide a couple months ago somebody
shut down Heathrow Airport because they
flew their drone to
over the airport Gaza which is the Civil
Aviation Safety Authority in Australia
regulates all our drone laws and they've
recently updated their can I fly their
drone app to the open skies app if you
download the open sky app for both
Android and iPhone I'm gonna link it
down below with a couple of other things
to help you guys out here you can
actually find out where you're legally
allowed to fly what kind of limitations
there are and all depends if you're
flying recreationally or for commercial
use
so the can I fly their app is the old
version from cars though that's been
replaced by open sky and honestly can I
fly there was a half-decent
app but it was very buggy and glitchy
from what I found from the open sky app
it's a lot more user friendly and so
fast so going from a bugs point of view
however the basic rule of thumb is if
you're 5.5 k's anywhere in the radius of
an airport make sure you do not fly a
drone and if you're unsure open the open
sky app take a look and find out if you
can safely launch your drone the fourth
law is a basic one and also kind of
tricky to do in a sense so the 4th
Australian law states that you can only
fly one drone at any given time I don't
really understand how you're going to be
operating two drones at the same time
that seems a bit counterproductive and
well dangerous but yeah make sure you're
only flying one drone at a time and the
fifth law is super simple make sure you
respect everybody's privacy we don't
want anybody find their drones next to
somebody's window looking into things
and causing havoc around the street so
if your neighbors have some concerns
make sure you have a chat to them first
tell them that you're not gonna be
flying anywhere near their house or if
you're flying commercially make sure you
give everybody a proper warning before
you go and do your commercial shoot okay
so let's say you've been flying your
drone for a while now and you've
mastered the art of drone flying and
maybe you thinking to yourself that
drone cost me a lot of money I'd love to
make it back somehow
well if you're looking to become a
commercial pilot or offer your services
in a commercial industry you actually
need to be registered with Kaiser in
Australia there are a couple of things
to keep in mind here and one of the best
things to know
is the fact that if your drone is under
two kilos you actually fall into an
exemption category which makes becoming
a commercial pilot so much easier but
let's have a quick thing here if you
have a drone and you have a service to
offer somebody what's a quick way you're
able to start a business and actually
talk to somebody and start getting some
drone footage out there in the real
world
well in my experience the best way to
offer your services as a drone pilot in
any small town or any area that's
lacking these abilities is to simply go
out and knock on real estate agents
doors real estate agents love making
their ads stand out and drone photos and
drone videos make sure they pop so if
you're able to come in at a very
competitive price and make sure you're
giving extremely high-quality service
well real estate agents are going to
love you and you're going to be staying
up all night editing photos getting
those drone pictures out the door and
you're gonna have your first ever drone
business but before we get to any of
that you really have to make sure you
abide by the cars or safety laws and
register as an official drone pilot on
the cars or website so as I mentioned if
your drone falls under the 2 kilo weight
limit you actually fall in an exemption
category so this means you don't have to
go through all the cars of processes but
get your remote pilot's license get your
remote operational certificate and do
these very expensive and very long
training courses one of the great things
about owning a maverick air or a
maverick Pro maverick zoom is the fact
they all fall under the sub 2 kilo
category but basically to become a
commercially registered pilot with cars
are in the exclusion category all we
have to do is go online and fill out a
couple forms and make sure you inform
Kaza
that you're going to fly in a commercial
space from here on in however to get a
drone pilot's license in Australia with
a drone that weighs more than 2 kilos
you're gonna have to go to a training
course near your local city this
training course actually comprised of
two components and it's the remote
pilots license and the remote operator
certificate I think from memory takes
about three days to get both of these
and it is a little bit costly but again
it is well worth it if you
during that commercial space as I've
mentioned before there are a couple of
new drone laws coming to effect in
potentially early 2020 so Caza has sent
out a mass email to everybody on its
drone emailing list stating a couple of
the different facts and a couple of the
new laws that may potentially come in
early 2020 there are a few things that I
personally think are great for the drone
community and a few things that are
going to really discourage people from
owning a drone and making drones seem
even worse than they are in the public
eye today so regardless if you're
planning on using a drone for
recreational fun purposes or if you're
planning on using it as a commercial
drone you're gonna have to register it
with the Casa Association so when you
think about it it's great that everybody
has to be registered but having
everybody registered means somebody in
the background has to set all this up
which means it's going to cost you money
to have a registration every single year
at the moment if you're thinking of
owning a recreational drone and flying
it whenever once twice a million times a
year it's potentially going to cost you
about $30 a year just to have this drone
registration on the flip side if you're
thinking about becoming a commercially
registered pilot along with all those
remote pilot license and remote operator
certificate fees you're also gonna have
to pay a yearly fee to keep your remote
pilot license and your drone registered
at the moment from what I've been told
it's about two hundred and fifty dollars
really just to keep your license the
second proposed change is something
that's well it should be pretty obvious
but I guess as a kids grow up you feel
they're more and more like adults and
you give them a lot more responsibility
and you stop watching over them
eventually however now they're proposing
that anybody under the age of 16 is
going to have to be supervised by an
adult when flying a drone now this is
great for somebody who's irresponsible
and maybe risking other people's lives
by flying a drone over into an airport
however it also is discouraging at
younger kids and younger photographers
videographers cinematographers from
reaching into this industry and really
honing their skills in before they go
out into the real world and start
exploring these potential opportunities
so in my opinion I'm not really too sure
if this is a good thing or a bad thing
but I think the kids that are really
passionate about photography and
videography especially drone photography
they're gonna be happy with their
parents or any adult standing next to
them at all times as they fly the drone
and they're still gonna be just as
passionate and love it just as much
thanks so much for watching guys that's
all I have for you today if you enjoyed
the video make sure you smash that
subscribe button maybe drop a comment
let me know what you thought and as
always I'll see you next Monday